ils devront s'inscrire aujourd'hui on se
trouve pour une petite compilation de
jeux on commence tout de suite avec
titeuf simulator ce chai le plus mignon
du monde regardez le flécher
délicatement avec des papillons pour
d'entrée de jeu est là on peut bouger ou
quoi oui je suis un jeune chat qui joue
dans le pré avec des papillons et avec
le jeu qui rame à mort et qui a bref ps
a dit qu il soit il fait un petit bruit
c'est regarder vous avez vu du moment il
fait pareil qu elle atterrit et qui sont
un peu trop avec le poids de son ventre
est tous humains ils souffrent quoi on
peut jouer à la balle bon bien sûr gardé
le flou il fait sa toilette
c'est horrible et jeux comme ça terme
l'impression d'être l'homme le plus tôt
baies du monde attend il ya une quête à
temps par an infligée lundi avec photos
et du prêtre c'est ça ou alors du
paladin aux déboires dérogation aux
présentes les terrains de jeu je crois
c'est ça oh mon dieu je joue sur des
champignons et le sémillant la ville me
caresser comme ça et toi ton chien dans
la vraie vie fais pas ça non il te
regarde les spiritueux doit toujours
plus de croquettes jour après jour fils
de chat du rabbin par exemple sur lui
[ __ ] mollet l'air un peu paralysé
paraplégiques mais les coen miniers ont
tout essayé on est resté paraplégique tu
bouges jamais jumbo a bouffé à pioncer
est encore plus beau faire quitte icahn
kitty le chat dont on a toujours tous
rêvé bientôt dans les bacs
ces blocs de verre ce à quoi comme si
c'est un [ __ ] de rythme plus d'avoir
séché voilà je fais preuve de
deschaseaux une nation total où j'ai mis
vingt minutes à trouver ce terme un
mélange de déshumanisation et de chats
trouvés tellement faible face à ça ça se
trouve c'est le démon qui nous tuera
tous et on lui fera jamais rien quand
même
ambre et un châle aurait déjà tué tous
ces papillons depuis une demi-heure on
est d'accord allez monsieur k way c'est
l'heure de se quitter et d'aller sur le
second jeu
on reste d'un animal maintenant nous
sommes sûr wipix fly quand les cochons
vol je fasse n'arrivera jamais à se
rendre à des bulls violente sur la tête
ça s'appelait pas dormi là le truc est
déjà tout fait quoi mais qu'est ce que
j'ai à faire je veux ta cliquez sur fly
est déjà construit qu'elle et moi
l'intérêt à moi ne me choque pas me
spoil
je veux créer mon propre truc attend le
muc c'est plus compliqué tu voulais vous
auquel va lui mettre des a directement
et un réacteur sur le dos voilà tous
trois une ambitieuse mais bas de gamme
ballereau directement on n'a pas le
temps nous vous savez bien voilà son
chapeau ça va être les listes comme ça
et cela va lui mettre sur le cul comme
ça c'est parti on est prêt attention je
met les gaz
c'est parti ouais et battant il vole ou
pas parce que je trouve athlétique et
chaque fois vous la faite celle-là dire
que je vous lance une vanne et pendant
ce temps là mon cochon ce matin mais
j'en ai marre moi je sais que mon cochon
nuls la mettez vous là on part sur un
décollage d'alger où je peux rien vous
le dire ça décolle ça des oui on va
c'est de faire un truc un peu mieux oui
c'est le cochon fusée au sein du bureau
de quoi il pèse ou pas il pèse ou pas
alors en dessous lui sa part en rubik's
cube mais très mal fait pas du tout
parallèle ça c'est en fait c'est une
roue voilà je sais pas pourquoi mais ces
pauvres bon jeu il n'a pas de paupières
on avait l'impression donc j'ai peur
qu'il attrape un peu mal aux yeux à
cause du soleil c'est pas une excuse
questa 6 2 plus tard ya un petit
réacteur bon j'avoue j'ai tout misé sur
le web si ça marche c'est parti quoi
attends régime a pas eu le temps de
comprendre ce qui se passait non mais
attends mais c'est scandaleux quoi
attendait non silhouette tout explose
quoi et pour le camp même le soleil non
ça c'est cl ça serait pour contrôler
deux petites hélices aux plats chez pas
pourquoi mais je trouve ça assez jolie
et on a peut-être une note de style
convoi l'on sait pas alors ça voilà
c'est pour ça que j'ai mis triangle
comme ça il tombe un peu décollage
imminent voilà lâché en bella je suis
une [ __ ] de tondeuses quoi je tombe
chouette guitare dans le trail de cet
agriculteur je tournais aucun problème
et si je passe sur ta jambe ça la rasd
mesdames si vous voulez non mais
maintenant j'ai juste c'est le truc le
plus ridicule que j'ai vu depuis
longtemps quoi regarder la ja le chant
est bon niveau allez c'est parti ou
remuent la terre pour la fertiliser coup
c'est en fait c'est juste le fauteuil
roulant des cochons paraplégique quoi
vraiment ah oui avatar mais là on avait
un truc magique hop comme ça il va
commencer bien auteurs locaux
j'avais eu un peu de mal à y croire mais
on sait jamais des fois on a des petites
surprises j'étais ingénieur en aviation
ce fait je connais parfaitement la
physique un réacteur sur son [ __ ] de
d'autres cochon et en plus ils protègent
du soleil y tient c'est une bonne chose
touati twenty two hockey et le rond or
good grips it and trying to make
décollage et oui quand même mois deux
fois que c'est le pied
dégueulasse que ce cochon est connu et
on a vu des décollages en fait ça sert
qu'à tourner on peut pas les pencher à
sevran ou en bas pour pour aller vers le
bas vers le haut mais compris vous êtes
ingénieur aussi voilà ont passé le
brevet cette année ses dix ans d'écart
quoi lasser un simulateur de pêche
plante on peut le dire voilà ça se passe
de commentaire
paris joue plus j'en ai marre de vous mr
je vais sur son [ __ ] je lui se tromper
fallait sur les fesses faut le mettre
sur le dos ou là on est bien monsieur
oui à mettre des petites hélices à temps
mais c'est quoi c'est ridicule cette
hélice ou en espagne et nice ou net
c'est d'elie semoun non hélas il vole
pas jouer aux condamnés au scandale on
dirait retirer un cochon que fait la
vague avec ses bras on y va
progressivement
là je vous dis on part on parle comme ça
on ne voit plus près dans la
stratosphère up en sorte que pour être
bull comme l'outil l'a fait sauf qu'on
impute un de cochon non non non non non
non ouais pratique la retourner aux voix
le tour
cette fatalité qui colle à la peau a été
bruyamment problèmes d'accès je n'ai
plus les mots alors faut y aller voilà
suffit les conneries
en fait je pense que le plus gros
problème qu'on a c'est qu'il faut dé
rouen oui monsieur
ces dames nous préparons à décoller à
l'aide avions fait en partie à l'aide de
cartons ikea il est vrai jeu mais les
gars je répète je mets les gazous né
voilà je vais tenter de faire des
blagues pour vous détendre messieurs
dames
parce que la situation est extrêmement
tendue c'est parti on prend de
l'altitude je répète au procès face à
ben affleck ça marche tout va très très
bien
la température extérieure est de 8
degrés l'atterrissage est bientôt fini
voilà on a atterri quelques années c d
et voilà on se moque qui kiffe les
réacteurs sont partis faire
régulièrement n'y a pas de problème ne
vous en faites pas mesdames et messieurs
le vol de dix heures était fatigant pour
tout le monde de 10 secondes pardon il
est temps de passer au jeu suivant
nous sommes sur 60 ses gonds le streaker
voilà c'est l'histoire d'un mec est nu
et ou d'une fille qui est venue c'est
encore mieux pour nous et c'est pas
pourquoi il est nul mais du coup il sort
de chez lui et le but s'est affolé
absolument tout le monde dans la ville
voilà exactement comme ça par exemple
japonais le même le sapin est à feu les
voiliers prend feu il a peur de moi oui
quand allez vous mener le peuple attend
mais juste tu fais ça dans paris les
mecs de marpent toit en toit ils font en
canard c'est quoi ce mec c'est une
baleine ont peur de vous charmer à
télérama mechrara est bon a eu un score
de 50 c'est parfait on se refait une
game non non pas le mec a fait juste
offrir à manger parce que les parties
durent 60 secondes et c'est pile le
temps que tu mets à teulat c'est
totalement du jeu si fait que tu fais
partie puis tu veux plus jamais c'est
fini et bien c'est à dire point de cette
petite compilation
vidéo j'espère que vous a plus ces cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude les liens des jeux sans
exception si vous avez envie d'y jouer
on se retrouve très vite étendue de la
nouvelle vidéo tient tout le monde
puisse cette fois le chat mignon ça
dérange pas du tout évident mais tu ne
bois jamais pour toi il ya lille où bon
lui mahfoud radio direct attention
grosse menace à radio
[Musique]